il y a 4 ans le covid bousculit nos vies
mais que sait-on aujourd'hui des
origines de cette maladie de ce virus le
sarscov de con a pris 4 ans après et
bien c'est la question que nous allons
poser aujourd'hui et pour en parler je
suis avec Vincent bon bonjour Vincent
bonjour Vincent merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui on va se poser cette
question sur ses origines j'invite no
internautes bien sûr à poser leurs
questions on y répond au mieux comme
d'habitude 4 ans après est-ce que on a
on apprend encore des choses
régulièrement sur ces origines du covid
la période d'effervescence est est quand
même clairement passée hein le moment où
bon déjà le moment où tous les jours on
découvre des nouvelles choses sur le le
virus bien entendu c'est terminé euh et
ensuite il y a eu toute une période de
d'interrogation et de doutes sur cette
question des des origines avec des
travaux scientifiques d'une part d'autre
part des des
rumeurs de rumeurs qui pourraent se
propager sur une origine humaine sur une
origine animale dans dans un sens ou
dans l'autre là on est vraiment passé à
autre chose pour te dire avant de avant
de venir ici et de descendre je
regardais un peu les derniers papiers
qu'on Ava pu publier là-dessus j'ai
essayé de voir aussi au niveau de la
presse internationale ce qui pouvait
sortir ça fait quand même quelques mois
que rien de nouveau n'est sorti à la
fois chez nous mais aussi chez chez nos
confrères internationaux he que ce soit
la presse anglosaxonne que ce soit enfin
ou la presse ou la presse française on
reste là sur toujours le le même en fait
le même schéma c'est-à-dire que on on
on a un doute sur une période donnée
dans dans l'histoire du virus en gros
bon là on remonte à a 4 an le premier
mort à Wan on sait que Wan a joué un
rôle essentiel dans la propagation de ce
virus que ça a servi d'un d'incubateur
en quelque sorte qui a eu des des
contaminations dans dans dans cette
ville et que de de de ces contaminations
est partie à cette pandémie on sait
qu'on retrouve des traces de virus
quelques mois quelques années avant dans
les ha plateau au à la frontière
lausienne et chinoise avec des virus qui
sont très proches qu'on appelle qui
s'appelle le le banal c'est un virus qui
ressemble beaucoup au sarcor 2 qu'on
retrouve dans des chauves-souris et
entre les deux donc il y a quand même
5000 km qui s pas il y a quelques mois
quelques années qui sépare qui sépare
les deux enfin quelques années plutôt on
on est sur des scénarios toujours pareil
et là il faut réussir à comprendre ce
qui a pu se passer et tous les scénarios
sont sont crédibles enfin il y en a deux
de deux grands qui qui se qui se
dessinent et les deux les deux sont
crédibles et après il faut chercher des
indices pour aller dans un sens ou dans
l'autre le dernier élément vraiment
marquant euh sur sur cette quête des
origines c'est la publication de de
résultats ADN dans les cages du marché
de Wan alors il faut se rappeler quand
même ce que c'est que ce marché le
marché au marché au poissons si si je me
souviens bien son son nom on est quand
même dans un endroit qui a tout pour
être suspicieux avec des animaux qui qui
sont entassé dans des conditions
indigènes qui sont pas respecté une
proximité hyper importante entre des une
faune sauvage vivante et morte et des
êtres humains qui vont en plus se
nourrir vu qu'il y a des des échopesù on
peut manger donc on est vraiment dans
une simulation parfaite du début du
début de pandémie c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que ce marché avait été ciblé
et donc il y a quelques mois maintenant
on était au février ou en mars 2023 j'ai
j'ai plus la date exacte un papier a été
publié par des chercheurs chinois alors
à la fois ce papier et à la fois le
contexte de la publication est hyper
important ce papier mettait au jour la
présence de résidu ADN de sarsov 2 dans
des cages de chiens vivrin les chiens
vivrins c'est des espèces de de de
laveur alors pourquoi c'est
important parce que ça voudrait dire que
le virus a circulé sur le marché on est
fin on est aux alentours des
prélèvements été effectués en décembre
2019 donc on est vraiment au moment où
au début de la pandémie euh enfin avant
la début avant la pandémie au moment où
où le virus peut commencer à prendre son
essort et
donc pourquoi est-ce que le contexte est
aussi important parce qu'une fois que
ces papiers ont été mise au jour par une
chercheuse française qui il se trouve
qu'il y a un site internet sur lesquel
les scientifiques déposent toute leur
base de données viral c'est comme ça
qu'on contrôle les épidémies notamment
de de grippe et qu'on surveille
l'avancée de d'un certain nombre de
virus elle cherchit des informations sur
ce site là qui s'appelle g et elle tombe
sur cette base de données elle
interpelle les les scientifiques
là-dessus le papier retiré et alors là
on retourne dans une dans une boucle
infernale qui est de suspicion pourquoi
retirer ce papier alors qu'il du sarcov
2 et cetera quelques semaines après les
scientifiques republie parce qu'en fait
les bases de données correspondaient à
un papier qui n'avait pas été validé par
les paères donc il fallait qu'il y ait
tout ce ce processus là et les bases de
données ont été republié on a eu le le
fot le fot de de cette histoire on on a
bien donc des traces de de sarskcov 2
présentes sur le marché dans des dans
des cages donc qu' a des animaux alors
qu'est-ce est-ce que ça veut dire que le
virus est passé partie du du marché
c'est possible mais ça veut aussi ça
peut aussi vouloir dire que le virus a
été transporté dans le marché par un
autre lieu il y a notamment la question
de de ce laboratoire le laboratoire P4
sur le sur la ville sur la ville de Wan
à l'heure actuelle pour pour être
honnête il y a aucun élément qui permet
de de d'éliminer une des deux des deux
causes ce qui semble quand même plaider
le le le plus crédible et c'est de voir
une origine assez naturelle qui est liée
donc à ces conditions sur sur ce
marché-là un virus qui aurait circulé
peut-être à bas bruit dans les
populations aux alentour de des plateaux
dont je parlais au niveau au niveau de
la frontière la haussienne et chinoise
qu'ensuite des chauv-souris prélev ou
des animaux prélev pour aller sur ce
marché en contaminer les autres c'est
possible ce qui est aussi possible c'est
qu'un scientifique a fait parce qu'on
sait que ça a été le cas qui ont fait
des prélèvements dans ces grottesl de
chauve-souris été contaminé ramené le le
virus par le laboratoire et une
contamination ensuite par la la vie que
soit des prélèvements aussi au sein du
laboratoire tout ça tout ça est possible
mais on peut pas on peut malheureusement
pas pas prioriser un scénario sur les
autres il semblerait quand même que la
piste naturelle soit celle qui est le
plus de crédit auprès de la communauté
scientifique désormais il y avait un
certain nombre de questions qui se
posaient notamment sur les question des
manipulations peut-être que on y
reviendra mais aujourd'hui la plupart
des des scientifiqu le consensus les
écartes oui qui préilég plutôt cette
piste là la la grande question aussi qui
se pose c'est et on le voit sur ces
images l'OMS qui était venu en 2021
venir faire une enquête dans ce marché
justement la Chine bloque toujours et en
fait c'est qu'il y a un narratif qui est
celui de la Chine et c'est pour ça
que l'histoire de de de ces prélements
ADN avait avait posé beaucoup de de
problème c'est que le narratif de la
Chine je le répète hein on l'oublie un
peu ici c'est qu'il s'agit d'un virus
importé aux États-Unis par du surgelé ça
c'est toujours le narratif officiel dans
dans dans le pays et donc trouver des
traces de sarscov 2 à avant la pandémie
sur le marché Duan mais ça va pas dans
le bon sens donc le narratif de la Chine
il colle de toute façon pas avec une
manipulation avec une fille du labo ou
avec un schéma naturel est-ce que c'est
crédible d'ailleurs de non objectivement
c'est pas crédible parce que ce que je
racontais c'est que les données
scientifiques qui ont été publié et
vraiment il il y a peu voir pas du tout
de raison d'en douter sont des tous les
scientifiques de la terre se sont penché
de dessus quand ils sont publié dans des
revues à relecture et puis il y a cette
autre lecture qui est par les pères dans
la revue et puis après il y a le il y a
la relecture de la communauté
scientifique parce que c'est un sujet
qui passionne et quand il y a un
consensus là-dessus on peut considérer
que qu'on est quand même dans la réalité
on est on est on a cette certitude là
c'est euh des virus les plus les plus
proches virus connus sont sur ces
plateaux à la frontière la haienne
Chinoise c'est une équipe de l'Institut
Pasteur et marquois qui qui a mis au
jour cette cette découverte enfin qui a
mis au jour c'est ces virus et qui qui
est qui est on dit inventeur des des
virus c'est le terme qui est le terme
consacré qui est inventeur de de ces
virus les virus banales il manque à ces
virus une particularité génétique qui
permet un virus comme le sarscov 2
d'être hyper contagieux on appelle ça le
cite de clivage à la furine en gros
c'est ce qui permet au virus d'avoir
cette porte d'entrée dans dans nos
cellules et ce qui fait du du covid une
maladie si dangereuse et en plus le le
tropisme de contagion du du banal et
plus gastrique que respiratoire mais bon
on est sur des virus très proches donc
le virus a évolué alors pendant un temps
c'est dit le virus a évolué ce site de
clivage à la furine c'est quand même un
site vraiment vraiment particulier qui
existe chez des cousins du sarscov 2 le
sarscov 1 notamment euh est-ce que ça
pourrait être une manipulation en
laboratoire parce qu'on sait que à Wan
des travaux ont étaient faits sur des
gains de fonction les gains de fonction
en gros c'est des scientifiques essayent
de de d'interpréter de simuler ce que
pourrait faire la sélection naturelle
pour pouvoir devancer les épidémies
futures et proposer des des vaccins des
remèdes à à des futures maladies et donc
est-ce que euh eu sarskov 2 avec ce gain
de fonction tell tellement contagieux
qui correspond tellement à à euh à nos
cellules humaines ce serait pas le
résultat donc de d'un virus banal
transformé alors maintenant ça c'est
plutôt exclu c'est même enfin c'est
c'est quand même ça ça semble exclu par
par la par la communauté scientifique
parce qu'on sait que un site de clivage
à la purine peut AR peut apparaître
naturellement c'est ça a été le cas dans
les années 90 d'une épisode de de grippe
euh animale alors je sais plus c'est une
grippe aviaire ou chez des chez les
petits mamifères j'ai un doute à
l'instant mais dans les années 90 en
Amérique latine on a vu ce site de
clivage à furine apparaître en l'espace
de quelques mois et donc l'épidémie a a
a progressé en peu de temps et à
contaminer les humains euh et de plus
les résultats génétiques sur le sur le
sur le marché tant a prouvver que il y a
eu une apparition une apparition
naturelle parce que on on recentre le le
marché au cœur au cœur au cœur au cœur
de de de nos recherches
et et donc donc il y avait cette
question de de la manipulation qui quand
même aujourd'hui pour en fait pour faire
apparaître la manipulation il faudrait
faire intervenir beaucoup trop de
d'éléments extérieurs alors que dans le
scénario il y a pas besoin de ça pour
avoir un scénario hyper crédible et
hyper et hyper efficace pour expliquer
cette contagion donc reste cette
question c'est est-ce que le virus était
gardé dans un laboratoire pas forcément
un laboratoire P4 mais un laboratoire de
Wan et qui a une contamination par
erreur une éprouvette qui se casse et
des choses toutes bêtes un un système de
surveillance pas respecté et cetera donc
ça c'est ça reste ça restera toujours
possible tant qu'on aura pas des données
qui sont les tests PCR de Novembre
Décembre
2019 on sait qu'il y a une grosse
épidémie de gripe àan à ce moment-là on
sait que des tests ont été fait on n'
pas les résultats qui ont été publiés
pourquoi parce que la Chine veut nous
cacher quelque chose objectivement j'en
sais rien et j'ai envie de dire c'est
sans doute pas le cas parce que je pense
que s'il y avait des choses on le
saurait on n'a pas les donné sans doute
parce que la Chine considère qu'elle n'a
pas nous les donné parce que elles ne
sont pas importantes pour l'enquête la
Chine est quand même dans une dans une
bataille un peu politique vis-à-vis de
de des États-Unis mais aussi de de
l'Europe qui est de de montrer que c'est
un État souverain qui participe à qui
participe comme elle veut à la recherche
des d'origine et qui surtout n'a pas de
leçon à recevoir des autres et ce cet
élément là est hyper important pour pour
comprendre un peu ce ce flou qui entour
qui entoure tout ça peut-être que la
Chine ne dit rien parce qu'il y a des
choses à cacher mais c'est aussi
crédible voire plus crédible que la
Chine ne dit rien parce qu'elle
considère qu'elle a toutti et qu'elle
n'a pas ê plus transparente transparente
qu'elle n'est et donc elle sert son
narratif là qui est des viandes
surgelées mais sans apporter d'éléments
concrets là-dessus quoi h oui donc la
question c'est est-ce que on saura un
jour en fait est-ce que là ça fait vous
n dites ça fait depuis mars dernier
qu'on a pas eu d'avancé plus ou
significatif il y a eu les États-Unis
qui ont qui ont levé en juin des des
documents classés mais qui raconte ce
que je viens de raconter c'est-à-dire
que on a aucun élément qui permet de
faire pencher la balance d'un sens ou
dans l'autre que a priori la piste
naturelle est privilégiée que la
manipulation du virus semble totalement
exclu euh au vu du des données
génétiques dont on dont on dispose
aujourd'hui euh voilà reste ensuite à
savoir quelle manière est-ce que naturel
est-ce que c'est une transmission 100 %
humage jusqu'au marché ou est-ce qu'il y
a une transmission humaine par un
prélèvement dans les grottes dans les
laboratoires par les scientifique et
cetera est-ce est-ce qu'on saura du coup
un jour ce qui s'est passé ou est-ce que
justement on va rester dans ce dans dans
ce flou puisque la Chine comme vous le
dites pour elle a tout dit n'a pas
besoin de faire plus on est bloqué est
est-ce que ça va est-ce que ça va encore
bouger alors j'ai j'ai j'en sais rien
mais j'ai envie de dire que le fait de
pas avoir d'information depuis plusieurs
mois en fait c'est plutôt un motif
d'espoir là-dessus
parce que on on s'éloigne du du brois un
peu médiatique bien entendu sur ces
questions avec un temps de un temps de
médiatisation qui correspond pas au
temps de la recherche on a vécu pendant
le covid une période extraordinaire dans
tous les sens du terme et notamment pour
la science qui a été contraint à des
délais qui ne sont pas les siens et
notamment qui a été contraint de des
médiatiques je reviens sur la pandémie
est-ce qu'il faut déconfiner quand
est-ce qu'il faut déconfiner
est-ce que le virus est transmissible de
telle manière des des questions
auxquelles on avait pas de réponse et
sur lesquelles il a fallu apporter des
réponse donc on a été dans dans ce BR
qui a contribué notamment à bah
l'explosion d'un certain nombre de de
mauvaises pistes pour utiliser une une
litote et je pense notamment à
l'hydroxychloroine parce qu'il fallait
apporter des réponses tout de suite le
temps de la science c'est pas celui-là
c'est pas le temps médiatique et c'est
un temps long normalement les débats se
font en cachette par biais de de revue
d'articles scientifiques étayés des
discussions là-dessus des articles
interposés donc là on sait qu'il y a des
scientifiques qui travaillent là-dessus
un certain nombre de scientifiques qui
sont intéressés par cette question qui
qui analysent des données qui font des
enquêtes qui mènent des enquêtes sur le
terrain je parlais de marqu et loi à à
Pasteur je parlais de de de la
scientifique Florence Deb qui avait qui
a mis au jour ses données génétiques
donc on sait que ces équipes là on peut
parler aussi de l'équipe de Bruno canard
pour parler que des Français à Marseille
ces équipes là continuent à travailler
sur sur le covid euh que à travers le
monde il sont un certain nombre et que
espérons qu'un jour ce ce travail paye
euh euh en tout cas ce ce silence
médiatique leur est utile parce que il
laisse le temps d'avoir une pré analyse
de de contrebalancer des des des pistes
pour éviter de de de donner une fausse
piste comme comme comme une réponse
après est-ce que le leur travail pra ça
objectivement j'en sais rien euh j'en
sais rien le fait est que euh la Chine
coopère toujours aussi peu pour les
raisons que que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure euh et que ça reste ça reste
problématique et tant qu'un certain
nombre de données précises et notamment
j'ai expliqué les les résultats pestr de
cette épidémie de grippe à Wan en
Novembre Décembre 2019 avant que le le
covid démar parce qu'on peut avoir là
alors c'est très possible que ce soit
pas le cas parce que ils ont donné mais
on peut aussi avoir un un ancêtre du
sarcov 2 moins létal mais tout aussi
contagieux qui aurait donné symptômes
plus gripaux qui aurait muté dans un
environnement naturel ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il y a des prélèvements qui ont
été fait aux alentours de des
plateaux à la frontière laoienne et
chinoise auprès des populations c'est
qu'il y a pas eu de circulation à Bab du
virus dans ces populations là par par
les les chauv-souris donc on n pas eu un
virus qui a contaminé des hommes et des
femmes dans cette zoneel et qui après
qui aurait circulé VI les populations
humaines et qui aurait muté là-dessus ce
scénario semble assez écarté parce que
des prélèvementérolog ont été effectués
et on voit pas d'anticorps qui
correspondrait à à un tel scénario
autour de de de ces populations oui donc
c'est plutôt quelque chose qui est venu
qui qui est venu de ces grand jusqu'à
one directement voà c'est pour ça on
privilégie vraiment l'histoire du du
transfert animal alors que ce soit
scientifique ou que ce soit pour se
nourrir c'est c'est toute la question
après en science c'est toujours ça qui
est compliqué c'est que la l'absence de
preuve n'est pas preuve de l'absence
c'est pas parce qu'on a pas trouvé
quelque chose que on finira pas le de
trouver mais on dit toujours on tend à
croire on va vers c c possib
et cette idée que il y a une circulation
à Bar est pas priorisée pour le moment
parce que les les résultats ne vont pas
dans ce sens là alors pour revenir un
peu plutôt sur sur la maladie sur sur le
sur le covid en France les gens ont
toujours le covid on n'est plus du tout
dans les mêmes cas qu'il y a par exemple
3 ans et demi en France c'est sûr est-ce
que pour autant le covid c'est c'est une
maladie qui est derrière nous alors les
alors est-ce que c'est maladie qui est
derrière
nous le sarscov 2 donc le virus de covid
parti IPE à l'instar du VRS
virusocolique et des virus grippaux aux
épidémies hivernales de de virus
respiratoire
aigu aujourd'hui selon les données de
sentier public France depuis le mois
d'octobre à peu près il y a plus de 400
personnes qui ont quand même été qui ont
été pris en charge dans un système de
soins intensif à cause du covid pour
comparaison on est à une centaine pour
pour la grippe donc ça reste un un
sachant que l'épidémie grippe on est au
tout début hein donc le le pire sur
cette sur cette maladie on est quand
même sur un virus qui continue à à
circuler à à être dangereux pour un
certain nombre de personnes on sait qui
sont ces personnes les personnes
immunodéprimées donc qui ont des
traitements pour des maladies lourdes
comme comme des cancers des personnes
les personnes âgées on a des
outils pour protéger ces personnes avec
les vaccins et aussi avec des
traitements comme le Pax clovid qui qui
est un traitement efficace une fois que
le test est positif et qui est encore
encore sous-utilisé selon les données
l'incerme en 2021 le covid est resté
quand même la la troisème cause de de
décès dans le pays donc c'est c'est
c'est des chiffres qui vont sans dout
diminuer mais le covid s'est installé
qu'on arrive toujours pas à cerner c'est
un peu le le rythme de cette de cette
maladie c'est-à-dire que contrairement à
la grippe qui a vraiment un rythme
saisonnier c'est ce que je disais là on
sait qu'on on va vers l'épidémie de
gripe ça se voit c'est en train de
monter on a les les indicateurs les les
outils de de de suivi qui sont assez
efficaces dans le pays et qui nous
permettent de de savoir que l'épidémie
l'épidémie arrive pareil pour la la
broncholite on sait que le gros de
l'épidémie est derrière nous le pic le
pic est passé mais il y a vraiment un
pic pendant l'année pour ces deux
maladies le covid on est vraiment sur un
un scénario de vague qui est plus lié à
l'arrivée de de nouveaux variants et en
fait à la fatigue de notre imunité par
rapport par rapport à ce virus là on est
sur on est dans un système de de décru
c'est qu'on a passé un pic qui était pas
très élevé par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu par le passé on a passé un pic euh
donc on est sur un stable de décru sur
on est sur une dynamique de décru ce qui
semble se dessiner c'est que dans
quelques mois on est un nouvel Haos et
ainsi de suite et que ce soit pas
drivrivé par par le par la saison voilà
mais mais vraiment par par cette
question de de variant et qui expliqueon
est des des des pics en été faut se
souvenir que en 2000 alors j'ai toujours
du mal sur les dates mais 2021 on avait
eu un pic au mois de de juillet c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui avait contraint le
gouvernement à mettre en place cette
histoire de de passe sanitaire on s'en
on s'en souvient avec les cinémas qui
restaient notamment qui restaient ouvert
seulement pour pour les personnes
vaccinées donc il avait eu toute toute
un tout un truc
làdessus
donc donc donc on est on est pour le
moment sur sur ce sur cet élément là
après il est pas à exclure que dans les
les mois dans les années à venir cette
circulation se stabilise et se calque
sur un modèle plus plus habituel plus
plus saisonier puisque on peut peut-être
tomber plus souvent malade puisque voilà
les conditions sont plus propices à la à
la contamination de fait parce qu'on est
enfermé exactement c'est ce qu'on ronté
en 2 2020 en sens sou
effectivement effectivement est-ce que-
est-ce que pour autant on peut dire que
dans que le covid va rester dans cette
forme là ou est-ce que il y a encore un
risque que ça ressurgisse comme une
maladie grave alors le le risque de de
pandémie est toujours prise au sérieux
par les instance internationale l'OMS en
tête et puis même en France la nrsmie
qui qui surveille surveille ça mais
honnêalement c'est pas le le covid qui
qui inquiète le plus maintenant enfin il
faut quand même se rappeler que entre
les vaccins les contaminations
naturelles la plupart enfin l'immense
majorité enfin même je pense la totalité
de la population a dans son système
immunitaire les les outils qui lui
permettent de de répondre à un virus
proche du sarscov 2 et même si le virus
mute on restera toujours sur un virus
qui sera proche la question c'est
toujours
euh et en plus comme on a on a une
circulation qui est assez régulière on a
des recontaminations qui restimulent ce
système immunitaire donc ce qui fait que
il y a pas de de perte de de mémoire de
de de de l'immunité en tout cas chez les
chez les chez les personnes en bonne
santé c'est pour ça que le vaccin est
seulement recommandé pour les pour les
plus âgés pour les personnes
immunodéprimé donc le le le risque est
quand même est quand même très très
faible après on est jamais à l'abri
d'une mutation extraordinaire qui
toucherait une partie du virus qui le
rendrait totalement totalement inconnu
et qui lu permettrait de déjouer mais l'
ça reste une
science ça reste une science quand même
assez efficace dans la plupart du temps
c'est-à-dire que quand un virus rentre
dans notre organisme il est il fait il
doit déjouer un certain nombre de
défense une humilité innée une humilité
acquis et que tous ces éléments là par
rapport à SC 2 sont maintenant bien
rodés chez chez chez la plupart des gens
effectivement merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi vous pouvez bien sûr
retrouver tous les articles de la
science sur le Figaro et moi je vous dis
je vous souhaite une bonne journée sur
le site du Figaro et sur Figaro
live